اكثر من 50 مليون قناه على يوتيوب حول
العالم في وقت يتسابق كثير من المدونين
استعراض اكبر قدر من تفاصيل حياتها وذلك
لتحقيق اعلى عدد من المشاهدات هناك ايضا
قناه ام وليد على يوتيوب الطباخ الجزائريه
التي لم يظهر وجهها ابدا على مدار سبع
سنوات ام وليد او مطبخ ام وليد الذي يتابع
قناتها اكثر من احد عشر مليون مشترك اثاره
الجدل مؤخرا بعدما كشف الموقع الامريكي
نتورك عن ارباح القياسيه تحققها قناتها
الموقع شارع ان ثروه وليد من يوتيوب قد
تصل الى اربعه ملايين دولار واكثر وربما
تحقق ما يزيد على 55,000$ شهريا
لكن ام وليد خرجت عن صوتها وكشفت ان ما
ورد عن ثروتها غير دقيق واينما تتقاضى
مبالغ صغيره حسب عدد المشاهدات والمشتركين
مقاطع ام وليد حققت نحو ملياري ونصف
المليار مشاهده منذ اطلاق القناه وتعتبر
اول امراه في المغرب العربي تحقق هذا
العدد من المشتركين والمشاهدات المزيد حول
الارباح وكم يجني يوتيوب نفسه من مستخدمين
والاعلانات معاها
لنبدا من مستر بين الذي يتابعه
124 مليون مستخدم عبر قناته على يوتيوب من
المتوقع ان تصل اربحه بنهايه العام الى
110 ملايين دولار واليكم المزيد من
الارقام 70% من مستخدم يوتيوب اجره عمليه
شراء بعد مشاهده اعلان على المنصه
237 مليون
150,000 دولار هو ما انفقته شركه ابل على
اعلانات يوتيوب خلال عامين 2020 و 2000 و
2021 12 مليار دولار هو ما انفقه المعلنون
خلال الاشهر الاربع الاولى من عام 2022
وهو ما يمثل وزياده قدرها
325% مما انفقه خلال نفس الفتره في 2021
ايضا اكثر من سبعه مليارات دولار امريكي
يوتيوب في جميع ان العالم خلال الربع
الثالث من 2022 وهو انخفاض بنسبه 2% على
اساس سنوي
[موسيقى]
في فقره الجنوب الاقتصادي معنا كمجرات
العددين الجميله سمر المشاطه
سمر اهلا بك يعني عرفنا كثير من الاشخاص
مهنه يوتيوب
[تصفيق]
غير انه لازم تكون مناسب للمنطقه اللي انت
فيها طبعا هذا يعتمد ايضا على جنسيتك يعني
في جنسيات معينه تاخذ
اهتمام اكثر من جنسيات اخرى بعدين همم
بدايه لازم تكون اسهل طريقه لعمل الفلوس
على اليوتيوب غير انه تبيعين منتج او
سبونسر شيب هي عن طريق اعلانات جوجل العدس
مال جوجل شلون انت لازم يكون عندك ميني
مام 1000 متابعه وسبسكرايببر بس وا 4000
مشاهده على مدى عام الان يصير نجيبهم
الموظفين بالشركه
ويا يوتيوب ويجيب لك الاعلانات مال جوجل
الان كل 1,000 مشاهده للاعلان مو للفيديو
اللي يتابع لك كل 1000 مشاهده للاعلان
تاخذين عليها 18 دولار كل 1000 مشاهده
يوتيوب
اه طبعا الانستغرام الانستغرام شيء اخر
يعني شيء منفصل والسناب شات شيء منفصل
ايضا هسه نتكلم عليه طيب همم سمر اليوم
يعني انطلاقا من هذا الكلام كنا بالزمنات
بدنا انه اولادنا او نحن ننتهينا مهن
محدده يعني مثلا نقول بدنا دكتور بدنا
مهندس بدنا رجل اعمال عشان يطلع مصاري هل
اليوم نقدر نحكي انه صارت فكره اليوتيوبر
مهنه وتجاره رابحه من كل كم من كل كم الف
يوتيوبر لا ينجح يوتيوبر واحد بعدين في
مهن معينه هي مو مهن المستدامه يعني اوكي
تطلع على الموضه ثلاث سنين اربع سنين روحي
خمس سنين بس وبعدين لما يصير عمرها
بالاربعين لما يصير عمرها بالخمسين بينما
دكتور مهند اخرى انت كل ما يصير عندك خبره
لك قيمه
لحد الان اكيد هي مو مهنه الناس هذا يعني
يوتيوبر كان يعني يبقى يقدم محتوى بس شيء
تحدي كبير ومنافسه كبيره مو سهله
عن اربع ملايين دولار تدخلها الى اي مدى
يصل دخل المؤثرين اللي نعرفهم تعرفيهم
شاهدين البارحه اتصلت بشركه نايل سفن وان
هي احدى الشركات المسؤوله هنا عن تسويق او
التعامل مع الانفلونزا وربطهم بالماركات
اليوم الشركه خبرتني طبعا حسب كل شيء
اعتمد على
الانفلونزاروين وهو من وين بالنسبه
للمنطقه جدا يعتمد عندي تعتمد على الدفع
اكثر او المشهور اكثر هو السناب شات فياخذ
اللي عنده 100,000 ياخذ 2,000 دولار فما
فوق على البوست الواحد الاستوري ارخص
بينما اذا عندها 500,000 يعني نص مليون
فما فوق ياخذ اربعه الاف دولار بلس على
البوست الواحد بس على سناب همم هذا الحكي
بالسعوديه بالنسبه
ااستغرام بالنسبه للسناب شات اغلى ياخذ
تقريبا اذا عندك نص مليون فلور اكثر من
5000$ على
الامارات ههه
اكثر الانستغرام يلا شدي حيلك ما بقدر ال
100 الف دولار تقريبا لان سوري 100 الف
ولاور ياخذ 2,000 دولار فما فوق على
البوست واربعه الاف دولار فما فوق على
البوست بينما السناب شات اقل في الكويت
اقل تقريبا 1000 اذا 1000$ على البوست
لانه يمكن البوبيليشن ابل في مصر مثلا
بوبيلاشن اعلى بس القوه الشرائيه اقل
الاشخاص فقال عندك احتماليه انه هذا الشخص
يسوي شوبينج اللي الحين على الانستغرام
تقريبا 44% من المستخدمين يسوون قرار شراء
على الاقل واحد على الانستغرام بالاسبوع
فهذا بس هذا الكلام اقل في مصر لدى
الانفلونسر همم ياخذ فلوس اقل او يتشرج
اقل تقريبا 500$ الى 1000$ ايضا في الاردن
ولبنان المغرب العربي على الفيسبوك
واليوتيوب هي اللي صار
في متابعين شكرا
الله كريم